i actually know
the name henry blodgett because
and i only hear it in your accent
watch it he's an old cox he's an
all-time card sucker yeah i mean
he is insider gun
i mean he's a crook yeah the man is yeah
yeah like what business do they talk
about yeah there's no business i don't
see articles but companies you could pay
to be on their site their pc
he he is
banned by the sec i mean that's that's
i'm not he was a he worked for i think
uh was it merrill or one of the big
firms yeah and he literally got caught
like telling his clients which or any
like
mom and pop people like buy this stock
and then his emails being like this
stock is trash he got one of the biggest
fines in the history the sec and he's
banned this guy is a legitimate crook
yeah and then he star business insider
talking about wall street i guess
they're scumbags um
and he's the guy who wants business
insider which by the way uh people
probably what's he talking about
their whole model they're bought by a
company that owns a german newspaper i
think is bilk their model is well known
it is just salacious headlines for
clicks that's what they do and they
coach it like they're this real business
thing they're not they're trash and i
paid a lot more attention since i've
been involved with them but it's like
every week it's somebody else that
they're doing the same [ __ ] it's [ __ ]
wild and behind the paywall behind the
page hilarious and then they admire
good for you literally every lawyer is
like it's gonna be almost impossible
your public figure like in in what
drives me nuts some of the [ __ ] they say
so
they can just play dumb they can just be
like we're a bad reporter what was said
to us we didn't do any bet somebody
could just date pointing to this day
porn into that
it's not their job to to do the due
diligence to see if it's the truth you
can be like oh yes we didn't know the
source yeah the source said that the
source was lying to us that's their
fault not yours but i don't give a [ __ ]
it's like i i need to see them in court
i literally there's another publication
i'm not saying the name because i've
learned i don't wanna
i don't wanna connect the thoughts
that's trying to do this
like is doing the same
same thing yeah and i found out about
it's the same like i'm getting all these
girls being like dave what's this about
i ambushed the reporter at her house i
found out where she lived
i did a [ __ ] stakeout for like five
hours i jumped out of the car you
personally yeah me personally wait so
you get in the car you're sitting out
there
it was like
they wrote that like we don't appreciate
that we'll talk to you when we're ready
it's like [ __ ] no it's like you're gonna
write this public you'll write the
article and then you'll like business
insider spent a year digging up [ __ ] on
me and they found nothing yeah and then
they gave me 24 hours 24 hours to be
like what do you say about this and that
they wrote a second article i had a leak
at business insider somebody sent me the
draft oh before they published it and
they tried to do the same this time
because they they're so vague i don't
even know what the [ __ ] they're talking
about yeah but i had time to figure it
out the second article so when they said
hey here's your 24 hours i was like bang
here's the facts change the total
article if i didn't have the leak there
would be things in there that are so
false and so over the top and things i
did they would have published it be like
oh we didn't know but because i had the
leak that's how [ __ ] up the whole
thing is it's like
i literally have an article that they
were ready to publish and if i didn't
have a mole they would have published it
wow but since i had the mole it gave me
more time to be like here's all the
texts here's everything lie lie live and
so you were ready um so the first time i
had no clue who they were talking about
so i got so blindsided i knew it was
coming but i didn't know the details one
of the girl there's star girl in the
first one
who literally says
in the article like we don't want she
she didn't want her name out there to
protect ourselves she went on tick-tock
said who she was launched and only fans
this girl is in the article saying i
don't like to be filmed she's a
full-blown pointer i'm not talking like
hey r-rated yeah she's like
as full-blown as you can like
double-team
it's crazy i don't care at this point
but have they ever mentioned that like
this is the girl who's the lead cloud
chasing yeah the lead headline yeah like
oh you feel me without consent that's
why i said to the reporter at i mean it
sounds rude when i ambushed the reporter
she's like do you film without consent
i'm like if a girl's giving you head on
her knees talking to the camera would
you say that say that's without consent
she's like no
i'm like i haven't checked no no no i
don't want to see it it's like well
like and what are we talking about yeah
exactly yeah it's crazy she's like why
haven't you said that it's like i've
been screaming from the rooftops
correct why did you go for a year and do
all this research i've got a video a
girl videoed a conversation in
before on my behalf and the report of
this new one she's like do you know his
ex-wife at all have you ever talked to
her what she like it's like nobody's
ever i was married to my ex-wife for
five years um she's still my best friend
no one's not once reached out to her be
like what kind of person is dave not
once wow because they don't want to know
anybody who says anything positive about
me yeah forget it they don't want it
yeah why do you think they're coming for
you
page views i mean i
there's a couple things i think i got
viewed as political so like this insider
only goes after people they perceive
elon musk now yeah yeah well it was
rogan right anybody trump then yoga yeah
and now they're doing musk and then
you're percolating in that i feel like
yeah there's those are the lily pads yup
they just keep jumping and i talk about
it which but you also go on like fox and
stuff like that totally
because they'll be talking about
something that aligns with something you
feel
would be like
and this is something that i am very
careful with as well yeah is they can
use you
as a mascot for something that you agree
with but then kind of wrap you into
other political totals
and i've always said that about me on
the political side i hate politics i
hate the extreme left i hate the extreme
right yeah you can ask me a question
you're not going to know the answer
based on what you think left or right
that's not how i am like i mean it's
just not
i remember i went on fox
one time with tucker carlson and it was
kaepernick and it was when nike signed
him and i was like to be honest i think
it's a great move by nike i think like
that the the urban market is going to
love it i think he's a perfect guy for
them and i
i got crucified by people being like
he's trash and kaepernick it's like i
they didn't even listen to what the
interview said like i was like i think
it's a great move so but if you go on
fox
you're hitler yeah it doesn't matter
what you say on fox if you're going to
tucker carlson they perceive you as
hitler and i've done my research on
most of the people i go on and i don't
find the smoking gun so i keep going on
and by the way
cnn or any of those people ask me on
i'll go on there
no i'll go on anywhere that i am like i
said
fox is [ __ ] huge they got a huge
audience i'm trying to grow our audience
yeah you asked me on a big program i'm
there with bells on yeah i'll be me yeah
yeah yeah it is interesting though that
like certain places are so radioactive
that's one of them but it's like he's a
huge show but to answer your questions i
also talk about these articles and they
put it behind the paywall so when i'm
screaming yeah guess what people want to
read what i'm screaming about so it
actually in a weird way plays into their
hands yeah and you only need a few
thousand people to recoup that
investment correct yeah now
how do you think
you've been politically polarized but
bar stool is neutral still yeah but
people i don't think view it that way
really yeah i think they i think they
view it as like guy culture and like
was it locker room stuff like fun like
ball busting but i don't think anybody's
like these are where the right wing
consists oh
no really
yeah yeah but those are people who
aren't paying attention but they do they
do yeah and we have everything i mean
listen people think we're like racist
white guys some people we have the
number one urban podcast in the country
or none like million dollars worth of
games [ __ ] huge yeah and they're
awesome but if you don't want to look
there you don't have to look there we
have a female ceo people say i hired her
just because you're female it's like
what do you wasn't even
do you know who jenna marbles is yeah
yeah so like
she worked for me i i discovered jenna
marble she was working at a tannis
tanning salon in boston i hired her yeah
and we started a site called stool a la
it was just the female version of bar
stool yeah we'd have smoke show pretty
girl she'd have smoke bro this is before
anybody ever called us sexist right the
only reason she left is she got huge so
like people just don't do the research
on us we're just trying to make people
laugh and if you want to say we're equal
opportunity haters fine yeah but like
there's never been somebody in our doors
who have said like this that the other
thing